[Music]
parks and recreation is a funny show
with a big heart and some of the series
bloopers are just as hilarious as the
show itself from improvised lines to
physical comedy here are just a few
bloopers that give the show's best jokes
a run for their money
if you've watched enough parks and
recreation you know the town of pawnee
is filled with cantankerous townspeople
none of whom seem happy with most of
leslie knope's efforts to make the town
a better place to live
uh you could resign
if you're up for it
as leslie played by amy poehler tries to
turn pawnee into a midwestern paradise
she faces off against the townspeople at
every turn to help control her
department's messaging leslie often
makes appearances on the local
television show pawning today run by
unhinged anchorwoman joan calamezzo the
callers who reach out to pawnee today
often have pretty far-fetched concerns
but in a blooper from season 2 the
caller's query is so ridiculous that
even comedy veteran amy poehler can't
keep a straight face in the bloopers for
the season 2 premiere episode pawnee zoo
after a caller asked leslie about her
work with animals they get to the
surprising crux of their question
i love him well what is it about cats
that make them think they are so much
goddamn better than we are i'll take my
answer i'll see you
parks and rec fans know about pawnee's
other animal issues but apparently the
town's citizens hate cats as well
parks and recreation has an amazing
roster of ridiculous supporting
characters but there's nobody quite like
jean-ralphio saperstein jean-ralphio is
a ball of disturbing erratic energy who
seems to exist only to party and cause
chaos in one of his first appearances
actor ben schwartz really pushes the
limits during a season 2 scene with
retta's character donna meagle in the
season 2 episode woman of the year jean
ralphio and tom try to convince donna to
join them as investors in the town's
local upscale club the snakehole lounge
in the original scene jean ralphio says
such invasive unsettling thanks to donna
that she declines to invest
what do you say sexy
i'm out why i hate that guy but in the
bloopers schwartz takes the whole
interaction even further between his
awkward improvisation and complete
obliviousness to personal space nobody
can keep from laughing john ralphio is
always hilarious but in the blooper
schwartz doubles down on his strangeness
turning his character's most off-putting
tendencies up to 11.
as a devoted public servant leslie is
dedicated to following every rule in the
book whether it's pawnee's ridiculous
town charter or the rules of polite
society in a season 3 blooper polar uses
a simple physical gag to show leslie's
adherence to observing the letter of the
law it also demonstrates her sweet
earnest nature which makes the whole
room laugh in a season 3 blooper when
tom haverford played by aziz ansari
bursts into one of the parks
department's offices to make an
announcement polar takes him extremely
literally ok cover your ears because
your head's about to explode
as soon as anzari looks back over at her
he can't help but laugh which sets off
the entire group polar has plenty of
improv comedy training and in little
moments like this it pays off perfectly
ron swanson might not be much of a
prankster in parks and recreation but he
does love to make his co-workers nervous
during a meeting in the season 3 episode
andy and april's fancy party he mentions
that he's been having some tooth pain
rather than go to the dentist he whips
out a pair of pliers and seemingly pulls
his tooth right then and there however
he then reveals to the cameras that he
had the tooth pulled the day before and
was just reenacting it to frighten his
colleagues in the outtake for the scene
however offerman ends up pulling out an
entire set of fake teeth instead
offerman will go to some pretty great
lengths for a joke but even he didn't
plan on going quite this far
rob lowe has been gracing the big and
small screen for several decades and has
plenty of friends in high places that
becomes evident in season 3 when a scene
is interrupted by low's real phone
ringing in his pocket startling
everybody on set
that's not good at all who is it though
former nbc topper scott sassa if you
must know salsa is an executive who
oversaw shows like the west wing during
his tenure at nbc so of course fuller
and co-star adam scott act appropriately
impressed as low mugs for the camera
though it used to be the norm for
sitcoms canned laughter has largely
fallen out of style and televised comedy
however if you watch the season 3
bloopers for parks and rec you may be
surprised to hear a lone laugh track
make an unplanned appearance the episode
jerry's paintings he's been trying to
teach childish andy and his wife april
played by aubry plaza how to live like
adults in one scene ben is horrified to
learn that the couple has been washing
their laundry with bubble bath instead
of detergent you wash your clothes in
bubble bath and bubble bath clothes soap
same thing no it's not well they both
make bubbles
so
while the televised scene ends there in
the blooper adam scott who plays ben
hits play on a small speaker playing the
laugh track
well they both make bubbles
neither pratt nor plaza can hold it
together even though plaza tries her
best to maintain april's deadpan
demeanor live tracks are definitely out
of place on parks and rec but when it
comes to the bloopers they fit right in
especially if the other cast members
don't see it coming
throughout the run of parks and
recreation chris pratt proved that he'd
do just about anything to get a laugh
and one of his best physical bloopers is
a result of a super physical scene he
performs in the show's fourth season in
the episode born and raised leslie tries
to prove that she was born in pawnee and
not the neighboring town of eagleton in
order to promote her memoir during her
run for city council andy operating as
his fbi alter ego burke macklin attempts
to steal her birth certificate to help
her prove her pawnee citizenship however
when he also brings back a stranger's
briefcase city manager chris trager
played by rob lowe tells him to return
it but in the outtake that part doesn't
go as planned with brad accidentally
destroying part of the set in the name
of comedy
[ __ ] hilarious that's not something
that props can fix it's already i'm out
as andy chris pratt always played the
perfect dimwit and his extraordinary
skill at portraying a simpleton is on
perfect display in the season 4 episode
the trial of leslie knope after her
secret relationship with her superior
ben is revealed leslie must defend
herself in court proving that their
tryst hasn't affected their professional
lives her friends including andy
scramble to help her win the case in the
scene leslie tells andy that she needs
help procuring evidence and tells him to
go to her office and look for a picture
of a female politician bella abzug next
to her desk she says the photo will help
lead him to where she's hidden some
documents however andy is still stuck
trying to figure out who bella abzug is
is that scary face funny hat gap tooth
or bill clinton's wife funny hat funny
hat after leslie clarifies which photo
she means she starts to describe a
complicated procedure involving locating
a hidden key however while she's talking
andy completely loses focus sending
polar into mild hysterics at the idea
that he's already gotten bored with
planning their office heist
out of all the parks and recreation's
notable improvisations few landed quite
as hilariously as chris pratt's risque
play on words during the season 4
episode the comeback kid during the
episode leslie tries to bounce back from
four polling numbers and launch a
campaign for pawnee city council she and
her best friend ann perkins try to rally
the troops by announcing that the
campaign's theme will be centered around
great comebacks like seabiscuit and
robert downey jr without missing a beat
brad also suggests reality star kim
kardashian which he rationalizes with a
highly inappropriate interpretation of
the word comeback
sending his co-stars into hysterics kim
kardashian kim well
in the video she gets she gets i think
though ann perkins might seem like a
sweet unassuming person she has earned
herself a devoted nemesis within the
parks department april ludgate april
bears a long-standing grudge against
leslie's closest friend thanks to ann's
previous relationship with andy as a
result april seizes any chance she can
to antagonize anne including a blooper
in which she uses her own dog and a
twisted ventriloquist act during a
meeting during season four as the
comeback kid april tries to irritate
anne by hiding behind her three-legged
rescue dog champion and pretending to be
him however in the outtakes aubry plaza
takes the already amusing schtick to a
new level as champion april jokes and
i'm in love with you
because you're just like me you're a dog
date me ann i'm single
the joke doesn't end there though in the
next blooper when ron agrees to
construct the stage for leslie's
campaign events he suggests that they
involve the talking dog plaza takes the
bait saying
and will you go out on a date with me
you're the prettiest dog i've ever seen
there's no doubt that chris pratt is an
excellent improviser but there's also
something seriously impressive about how
far he'll go to get his co-stars to
break and when it comes to the seemingly
inscrutable nick operman who like ron
swanson seems to always remain
expressionless brad sometimes has to go
the extra mile in the season six episode
new slogan andy tries to convince ron
he'll keep his secret by confessing all
of his own but in the bloopers pratt
goes off script revealing some pretty
unusual medical details to his
stone-faced boss he starts out by
telling ron that his head weighs upwards
of 85 pounds that he was a 16 pound baby
and that his mother carried him to full
term plus eight months when none of that
manages to crack ron's stoic expression
pratt keeps going until not even the
unflappable nick offerman can manage to
hold it together
i was born at 17 months
with a full head of hair
a full head of teeth
check out one of our newest videos right
here plus even more looper videos about
your favorite movies and tv shows are
coming soon subscribe to our youtube
channel and hit the bell so you don't
miss a single one
[Music]